what's up welcome back to the collider
interview Studio at Sundance 2024 I am
so lucky to be sitting with the team
behind out of my mind your movie filled
my heart I absolutely adored it huge
congratulations thank you I also must
say a big thank you to the fine folks at
filo who helped us get to Sundance this
year filo is a wonderful company that
puts the power to Greenlight movies in
the hands of fans and creators if you'd
like to learn more about filmo check out
their website
film. Amber you get my first question
it's the hardest question of the bunch a
lot of our audience is going to be first
learning about your movie through
Sundance so can you give everyone a
brief synopsis of out of my mind uh sure
so out of my mind is based on the
best-selling ya novel by Sharon M Draper
which is about a young girl named Melody
Brooks played by Phoebe who is
navigating sixth grade and she also uh
has cerebral paly and is non-verbal and
she's going through all the things that
we all go through when we go through
sixth grade so it's a kind of coming of
age um finding your voice but at the
same time everyone else around her
learning how to listen I got a two-park
question for you about signing on what
is it about the story that Drew you to
it but then also what is it about this
opportunity that you thought you would
have something to gain from as a
director evolving your craft you know I
wish I could say that I was smart enough
to have seen how much I would gain from
doing this movie at the beginning but
I've got to be really honest that I
walked away with so much like just
personal um knowledge and gratitude and
Joy from doing this and I I didn't
foresee that in the beginning I mean I
loved the story I loved the book I loved
the script I loved you know all of the
players The Producers all of that part
um and I I just I knew it was an
important story to tell but I couldn't
have foreseen how life-changing it was
going to be getting to do it so I love
hearing that all right phoe Ray you're
getting my next question this is
incredible you're so good in this movie
oh thank you what were you most afraid
of in terms of making your first movie
and how did you overcome it I was I'm
not a very confident person um so I was
really nervous about everything cuz
obviously this is my
first experience of acting but
um as soon as I met all these lovely
people it all got easier and
less back in cuz these people are so
genuine and nice you're a natural
seriously you should be very proud of
yourself I'm going to continue down that
path it's time to make a phoe ray blush
right now so this is her first feature I
have high hopes that if she wants to
keep going in this industry there will
be many more on the horizon can you each
name something about about her as a
scene partner or as a collaborator that
you appreciate that you're looking
forward to more filmmakers getting to
experience in the future I mean I have
so many things to say about Phoebe and
how amazing she is but I think my
favorite thing about her is her sense of
humor she makes me laugh so much and I
personally cannot wait to work with her
again so hopefully she doesn't get too
famous to not not remember who I am but
I I want to work with with her again
she's just a genuinely wonderful really
special smart funny kind thoughtful
person
I guess I'm going next um I think it was
her willingness to kind of make mistakes
and then learn from them I think we're
all like we want to be be perfect and be
perfect and I think Phoebe knew like
this is my first time and I'm probably
going to make some mistakes but I'm
going to get back on it and it kind of
made me be a better actress just to make
sure that I was there for her whenever
she was down and she was there for me
whenever I was down so it was perfect
best quality of having a collaborator
okay I have to say it's just how present
and available you were on set like just
even now just looking in your eyes
you're just very open and um and that
was really easy to act with yeah and it
was always different every time I felt
like you were always bringing a new
thing every every time to the
scene I I'd have
to say that I I I'd have to repeat what
everybody has said so far in terms of
the experience um it was the joy that
was so present uh also your joy in doing
this and your commitment and your
dedication and your professionalism I've
worked with people who aren't nearly as
dedicated or professional as you are and
that was really an outstanding quality
to me that you were there for everybody
and you made the experience
a joy for everybody and for me most of
all I mean in many ways like Amber said
transform my life thank you uh well it's
uh like that one might be the better
option you can have all of them if you'd
like
kby um for you know I pick a million
things it's Phoebe's fortitude and
strength is very uh impressive and
matched with her humor makes for you
know the best day at work that you can
hope for so um that's you know that's
about yeah I mean every that part and
then I mean I think with actors when
you're you have a scene partner you're
always looking to find like a connection
and intimacy with one another and God it
was so instantaneous because the courage
that you brought every day to this set
the vulnerability like you know it takes
us takes us like acting classes years to
tap into that and you brought it all and
the trust I was so grateful that you
like let me in you know what I mean like
we sometimes we can't find each other
when the camera's rolling and you are
right I mean I think I sometimes think I
am your mother sorry Frankie you know
what I mean because I just love you in a
way that I never had trust built so
quickly with an artist and I think it's
because of like the extraordinary human
being that you are I'm so excited for
people to learn who you are oh my gosh
thank you I thought I was her
mother Rose Maria I'll add to that a
little for you now because I feel like
this is true no matter what character
you play but in particular a mother I'm
sure you had a great script to work with
but I feel like it's often a situation
where you find so much of your character
via your scene Partners In this case
Phoebe and Luke can you tell me about a
quality of Diane's you only found VI
working with them these are good
questions um I would say a quality that
I only found I'll be honest you know
there's a piece of this that all these
characters advocate for Melody and I
really didn't find it until I mean I
probably shot three quars of the movie
by then that scene where we did in the
driveway and it was just the blocking
and the staging got a little precarious
to take Phoebe out of a wheelchair and
the level I didn't even know it was like
I was ready to quit the movie like if we
didn't like you know move things around
but like it just helped transform me
into what it really means to show up for
somebody and like Advocate and sometimes
we're scared in Hollywood to do that but
the the depth of our connection I was
like yeah no no I'm not going to sit her
on the back of this car you know I'm not
going to do it so I didn't even know I
had that in me to just look at the
producers and be like nope I'm drawing
the line but that really came from our
relationship was a really beautiful shot
and performance beat there um Luke I'm
going to come your way next cuz I want
to highlight Amber's work as well and I
know the two of you work together in the
past when you first met her what is
something about her that's signal to you
this isn't just someone I want to work
with once but this is someone I might
want to have a longlasting collaboration
with that did not happen that's not how
it
happened Amber and I met in a park uh uh
on March 2020 15th or 16th 2020 uh the
next day my wife called and said you
have to get on an airplane because
um but I we had the best uh just the
best conversation just a very create a
very
open uh creative conversation but a
human conversation and it didn't sort of
uh you know I I knew nothing about her
talents which are vast but you know we
sort of we forged a bit of a bond and a
friendship uh you know I think we share
a lot of uh frustrations about uh life
in the world and and and have high hopes
for uh for you know the experience um so
that was just the beginning of it and
and now I'm
trapped kind glad he's forever trapped
yeah he's promised to be in every single
movie I make now so I'm I'm already
looking forward to this um I'll open
this last question up to the group it's
also singing your Praises Amber I'm
going to borrow something Judith I read
from you in our uh press notes you
mentioned Amber is like Mrs V and away
she will push you can you each name a
time on this set when she pushed you and
by pushing you it helped you exceed your
own expectations for your work in the
film this is making me sweat can I go
first um there was a scene that we were
going to do that um we wanted to kind of
have multiple takes so we wanted to make
sure we had a moment where I was just
being serious about it but I wanted to
be emotional as well and um there was a
time that Amber pulled me to the side
and she just said listen I know that you
can do this you kind of just gave me
this really personable pep talk reminded
me of who I am in this character and
reminded me of the situation and kind of
just urged me to be my best self and
just to roll with it and it allowed me
to trust that she trusted me and I don't
think a lot of people kind of trust you
to do the work and I think she gave me
the opportunity to do that even with
just that little pep talk people try to
make you feel an emotion she just like I
you got this you know where you are you
know what you're doing you're having
this conversation and I just want you to
get a little more frustrated and it just
was it just was so helpful and it
allowed me to create the moment that you
do end up seeing which is a little more
subtle but it still feels pain you still
feel a little pain there so um I just I
thank you for that for trusting
me she she pushed me to do the
movie she did she did she was genuine
and available and supportive and things
that I talked to her about that I
thought needed to be there and she was
just open and there and present and I
thought oh this is a person I have to
work with I must work with her and um
like you now I'm hooked yeah yeah
absolutely I always get excited when
people build film making families so
keep this one
attacked I wouldn't even say pushed I I
would also just say like it's when you
see what's on the page which is
extraordinary and then you see the way
elevated it it's like you you push
yourself the hardest and the way that it
turned out just exceeded my wildest
expectations so it's that and that
doesn't happen a lot you know it's so
hard to make a movie that sometimes
you're just a little disappointed about
some parts of it but this is one that
every moment of the film was elevated by
your vision um and we're just really
lucky to be in your
orbit too what you got for us Michael um
right away I was thrown into a a very
hot classroom in front of like 20 12 13
year olds and Amber was like yeah just
teach and I was like what and she's like
well you know I I'm open improv so can
you just would you just teach a class I
was like are you kidding me so I'm
quickly Googling like you know some
facts about early explorers and stuff
and I was like I can't think I have a
lesson plan yeah I could do this I've
got a lesson plan I'm ready so she just
pushed me I think to really have to
embody the character in that practical
way like in a way that I hadn't thought
about I was leaning on the script you
know there's a script and so but I was
like oh what would I do that horrible
flop sweat feeling of just being in
front of kids and not even kids but like
pre-teens and early teens and even
though they were all actors they're
still young people with their judgments
and you just I'm standing there they're
just like oh they hate me I'm an idiot
I'm so not cool um so she she pushed me
out of my comfort zone I see I think I I
was just like wow he knows so much about
American
history oh that was just my
phone Google knows a lot about American
hist uh Luke Phoebe you got anything for
us I'm one com to mind but um there was
a scene where I had to get emotion
and I just couldn't for some reason but
Amor had to be really St with me which
I'm really grateful for cuz that got me
to the point where I could
play an emotional part and I'm just
grateful you there for me all the times
that when I needed
you all right Luke last up you gonna
take us home what was the
[Laughter]
question yeah pretty much basically that
you already said how great I think I
said that I mean we've established this
haven't we let's not Guild the
Lily uh
uh
sorry it just felt it felt natural at
this women were holding the microphone
for him sorry um the end on that uh it
was uh oh you know it's just like
it she asked for one mo One Moment in
particular where I really push you to be
the best thing you could
be or what is no you learned something
she push you to wear those dush you in a
way where you exceeded your own
expectations for your work like that um
well I think it is I do I do think
there's something about kind of put
putting a kind of trust in a director
where you you in some that in some
moments can sort of
you can kind of um relinquish an idea
about a through line of character and
story and really just for even a brief
moment become kind of like paint or you
know more become a little medium and let
the director kind of guide you and I
have that with Amber
where I just uh in spite of my you know
frustration or confusion about it I'll
just sort of go oh yeah let's try that
and uh and I I I've been sort of
surprised and happy to to see these
things make it into the movie and and
and and it does sort of reveal as a
viewer I kind of go oh I never I never
would have thought to do that and so
it's that that that is
um that's a gift yeah beautiful answers
all around I appreciate your time and
you sharing some of your experience with
us again congratulations on out of my
mind exceptional you so much thank you
thank you thank you thank you everyone
out there thank you for watching keep an
eye out for out of my mind and stay
tuned more from Sundance 2024 for you
soon